glenn you ready to roll
yeah how you doing brother doing good
how are you guys doing hi glenn
how are you for us sir oh man i got a
few so um
uh i recently got divorced about a year
ago after 13 years
where you look where are you located
california okay wow
okay yeah yeah it was interesting um
and it was like and even before that
i've dealt with other women in court you
know
other issues like uh false allegations
and stuff and had to beat that case
um which i did thank god but
you know there's stuff that it's just
like they don't realize the consequences
of these lies
and there's no accountability for them
you know like
when my wife me and my wife divorced it
came out because
she had three affairs in 10 years that i
didn't know about
she was accusing me the whole time and
i'm doing like trying to do the happy
wife thing
you know and trying to constantly prove
that i wasn't doing anything
i was working so much on making sure
that i wasn't
appearing to be doing anything bad that
i wasn't paying attention
to what she was actually doing yeah i
believe it and is that something that
you see in practice jonathan when it
comes to
um you know one party accusing the other
of infidelity it's usually them doing it
like you know they say that when you
point to somebody you've got three
fingers pointing back at yourself
yeah definitely definitely it's
projecting on you
what they're doing and they try to put
you on your heels
and that's just sick you know you
shouldn't have to deal with that kind of
stuff
but when you're married it's not easy to
get out of it and they just they'll
throw anything when they play
throw the kids involved too it's it's a
whole another a whole other thing it's
like
she didn't she didn't make any bad
claims in court
because there was nothing to make i mean
she was in the military so
originally and i was in the military and
i know that adultery is
actually an article 15 um a court
martial
you could actually get charged for
adultery if you're in the military
especially if you're
a senior enlisted and that she was
and i even submitted all the information
i have a video of her confession
i submitted it to um her her uh
leadership nothing happened didn't even
didn't even charge her
but again i know guys that when i was in
that was getting charged for
you know uh infidelity in the service
and they were losing rank they were
losing money you know
it is crazy do you think they didn't do
anything about it with her is it just
because she's a woman because she's a
woman
um you know she i mean that's just let's
just face it like she even he's so mad
when i say that you know men
are success objects women are beauty
objects you know men are the disposable
sex women are
the protected sex but it's like you know
stuff like this you know when you hear
these stories
it just it just reaffirms those
statements well then you know especially
when they try to alienate you from your
kids
that's the other strategy too yeah like
i mean me and my son
i haven't really had a good relationship
since the divorce she told him that i
you know that there was some you know
instances where she didn't feel that she
wanted to do things
and she i forced her i'm like
so i'm getting messages from my son
about stuff like that i'm like
you're alienating a child from his
father do you know how horrible
you are you're letting your hate for me
overwhelm you
over your love for your child happens
all the time
it's sickening it's sickening but
there's what's going on
accountability do you have any advice
for men on that one jonathan
can you get do you have any custody of
him can you get him into counseling i
mean oh yeah
so um i got a lawyer um and we we put
that
in the um divorce agreement that one he
has to maintain a certain grade point
average
um to be in her custody and two that he
has to go to uh counseling and she had
to pay for
um uh reconciliation counseling for
being my son
which hasn't happened yet you know but
um she already remarried she remarried
the guy that she was having
you know one of the guys that she was
having an affair with um you know so she
was married to him prior
she was married to me first and then she
during the last guy that she had an
affair with
she ended up marrying recently okay
yeah and i'm just like hey you're doing
me a favor thank you sir
do you guys live you live in the same
school district oh yeah we live like
three miles away
all right i mean she wiped me out like
financially
and then um you know how to you know re
rebound and uh go back home
i'm staying with my dad right now just
to kind of reassess but
sure you know like so since you're in
the private chat that she was made out
to look like a hero during the divorce
yeah because they didn't hold her
accountable for the infidelity based on
um military law nope um she made her way
pretty clean with uh family law i mean
she's
she's obviously had some success
alienating you from your kids and
doing a little bit of brainwashing along
the way which tends to happen along with
that
oh yeah i think it's a common theme for
women to do
and honestly in general because i had a
i have a daughter that's 16
and um her mother told me when she got
pregnant she had a miscarriage
i didn't find out for years later that i
had a daughter and then when i tried to
get in her life
you know her mother kept me out of her
life for 12 years just recently
my daughter knows the truth about what
her mom did but there's no
accountability factor i lost 16 years of
being in my daughter's life
you know and she had 16 years of being
told i'm a monster
and all this other oh sorry
rich for customer but um
you know it's like there's no
accountability for women
and that's the problem i mean that's why
i don't encourage guys getting married
at all yeah
that's i mean like bottom line don't
waste time and energy i mean i want to
hear jonathan's
uh you know take on this too but i don't
think it's a good use of your time
to try to hold women accountable there's
there's an entire
like genre and i've seen this out on
youtube now where like guys are like
trying to
hold women accountable publicly on their
streams and it's like
it doesn't work you know hold yourself
accountable first you know make some
better choices first
oh yeah like i think myself for a lot of
it i blame myself for being stupid
enough to believe a lot of it
and not that nothing everyone's bitten
twice shy right yeah it's just like you
know what
i'm mad at myself for not catching
things
when they were right in front of me and
thinking that like you know
all women are good like i was more mad
at myself over everything than anything
else
were you afraid to bring something up
are you walking on eggshells thinking if
i bring something up
you know yeah it happens all the time
especially when you want to question
things when things just don't add up
and you're like if i say this or i ask
this question
is it what am i going to be faced with
and that that's what kind of like led to
the whole
divorce it was just like okay you know
what this doesn't make sense
it smells wrong i'm going to ask her
when i ask her
oh you don't trust me you don't believe
me like well yeah you're giving me
reason not to
you know what do you think jonathan on
the whole accountability story on women
you know divorce yeah i think
i'm going to give you like an analogy of
how i look at modern day marriage
do you ever go to a carnival and there's
a
uh a basketball game
where you get three shots for a dollar
or three shots for five dollars you
could win a big stuffed animal
and you look at you like you're only
like five feet away from the rim
i'm gonna do it but what they don't tell
you is the rim
and it's not regulation size it's about
a centimeter larger than the basketball
itself
so your chances of having a successful
life long till death do you part
marriage are is similar to that it looks
good
and boy that payoff looks wonderful but
in reality it's like trying to make that
shot
through a rim that's a centimeter wider
than an actual ball
and you know you better think twice now
you could try it once
but you're silly keep going show me how
many people keep going back trying to
make that shot
yeah then it's kind of hilarious and
they keep on they'll feed that once
they're invested they'll just dump money
into it
and by the time they realize that they
could have just bought the bear
themselves
exactly exactly um like i'm
i'm of i'm in hollywood so i'm in the
industry and so i am a creator content
i'm like
creating some content coming out rich um
based actually your book
i've read your book and i've read and i
put a review on amazon on it thank you
um your book is spot on it's like rolos
but like a lot like practical it's like
you know
hey this is what you need to do um and
i'm actually
creating a a comedic video right now
a script um based on a lot of these
things like based on
you know going through something like
this being you know realizing the lie
how do you deal with it
you know like and it's all like funny
funny issues that i look at now that
i've been through in my life that are
not funny
but i laugh at now because of the
stupidity that
i had in in dealing with them
now you know now you know yeah that's
you know
send me an email when you get it done um
the email is on the about top of the
channel so send it over when you've got
a oh
yeah definitely will rich all right uh
glenn uh you got anything else for us on
this
um you know what not on this but just
thank you guys for uh this opportunity
great speaking with you you know and
everything yeah definitely uh by the way
rich um
uh paul is uh my counselor apex
yeah yeah my boy yeah that's my dude so
good
all right you guys take it easy
you